[Musica]
riflettendo sull'ipotesi di una vita
umana su marte argomento che come
abbiamo visto chiamò in causa il fascino
dell'esplorazione la sfida tecnologica e
senso assoluto della ricerca provo a
immedesimarmi in noi terrestri evoluti
ma diventati necessariamente cavernicoli
che guardiamo da lontano il nostro
pianeta d'origine per vederlo forse per
la prima volta per ciò che è un eden
probabilmente il pianeta più ricco di
vita più ospitale di tutto l'universo un
paradiso lontano solo ciò che trascorso
mutato scomparso rivela il suo volto
reale scriveva ha saggiamente il
terrestre e cesare pavese e allora forse
noi avremmo bisogno di guardare da
distante la nostra casa per capire che
cosa rischiamo di perdere per imparare a
non darla per scontata e poi
improvvisamente provare ad innamorarsi
di lei prima che diventi perduta lontana
scomparsa io faccio il musicista nelle
mie è più recenti esplorazioni sonore mi
sono trovato a fare musica senza
strumenti musicali esclusivamente con
rumori e ambienti sonori della natura
così facendo sono venuti in contatto con
delle stupefacenti meraviglie che hanno
voluto ha avuto la forza di creare un
legame empatico enorme fra me la natura
i suoi ecosistemi e le rispettive
fragilità ho deciso di raccogliere tutte
questa esperienza in un album musicale
che è contenuto all'interno di un libro
e fonia scritto con il geologo
ambientalista mario tozzi e che si
presenta in forma di prontuario di
innamoramento per la nostra casa
tutto è incominciato apparentemente per
caso un paio di anni fa sull'isola di
gozo un isoletta avvicina avvicinano a
malta durante una vacanza insieme
all'amico regista luca saini
sento parlare di roccia in grado di
emettere dei suoni
naturalmente mi incuriosisco
raggiungiamo non senza difficoltà questa
località suggestiva strapiombo sul mare
e incominciamo a percuotere delle pietre
con tutto ciò che troviamo interna
alcune di queste pietre effettivamente
rispondono con delle note per rispettiva
di formazione professionale io sono un
munito di un registratore digitale luca
di una telecamera
passeremo al pomeriggio sotto il sole a
picco a giocare con il suono di queste
pietre questo gioco si farà decisamente
più serio la sera quando allineando i
file sonori realizzeremo che tutte
queste pietre sono magicamente anche
inspiegabilmente intonate tra di loro
come strumenti di un'antica orchestra
preistorica che aspettava di essere
rivelata quindi qualche modo i più
antichi abitanti della terra le pietre e
come se ci avessero chiamato in quel
momento capisco anche di aver realizzato
per la prima volta un brano musicale con
i suoni della natura
[Applauso]
è come se avessimo capito che non
stavamo semplicemente giocando non
saremmo conciati come scappati di casa
abbrustoliti dal sole ma questo è
esattamente quello che vi ho descritto
nel momento in cui è successo per
apparente casualità
questo brano viene ascoltato da
michelangelo pistoletto
l'artista grandissimo artista che mi
chiama e mi domanda se sarei in grado di
realizzare qualcosa di simile con i
suoni i rumori dei fiumi di biella per
un'opera sonora da esporre all'interno
della sua meravigliosa città dell'arte
un'opera sonora non concettuale casacci
musica musicale temi crescendo
imprudentemente gli rispondo di sì
incominciando a sudare freddo
esattamente un minuto dopo perché un
conto è suonare una pietra che ti
risponde con una nota con conte
immaginare da dove andare a pescare un
elemento melodico dal rumore di un fiume
mi ritroverò ad errare con i miei
microfoni fra le sorgenti le sponde le
rive le magie dei mulini del torrente
cervo per cercare di capire che tipo di
storia sonora dovrei raccontare per la
prima volta mi rendo conto che senza uno
strumento musicale
non sono io protagonista
sono costretto a stare un passo indietro
nel processo creativo e a rimanere in
ascolto in quel caso spettatore della
maestosità della natura un ottimo
insegnamento tra l'altro imparando ad
ascoltare concentrandomi dal gorgogliare
dell'acqua delle sorgenti intra sento
una sorta di mormorio e che in effetti
una volta portato in studio e vocoder
izzato mi rivelerà la presenza di una
vocalità che intonata in alto creerà un
coro sacro perché le sorgenti del
torrente cervo e il suo primo percorso
accarezza dei luoghi di antica sacralità
sostituiti poi nel tempo dalle forme
della cristianità un'altra osservazione
una pozza con uno sgocciolamento gli
farà introdurre un idrofono un microfono
da immersione per catturare finalmente
una goccia che sta esprimendo una nota
da quella nota costruirò degli strumenti
immaginari e ancora successivamente da
una barra di plexiglass presente
all'interno della città dell'arte
puntata verso il torrente catturerà
un'armonica che mi regalerà una nota con
la quale esprimerà in qualche modo il
flusso del fiume
ascolterete questa sorta di sacralità
estratta dal gorgogliare della fonte
una nota di una goccia che ipnoticamente
cadenzata intonata sempre più in basso
ci porterà nel flusso del fiume quasi
una relazione inconscia con lo scorrere
dell'acqua e poi il flusso del torrente
cervo
[Musica]
lavorando sul suono di questo ipotetico
flusso ho la possibilità di dosare le
frequenze basse
oltre una certa soglia questo suono
diventa minaccioso ansiogeno al di sotto
di una certa soglia invece diventa
pacificante rilassante
un po come certa musica che sasuke si
ascolta per l'addormentamento ecco io
non ho assolutamente intenzione di fare
un brano rilassante
ho intenzione di inserire nella
complessità emotiva di quello che sto
facendo anche quel senso di minaccia che
noi associamo ai nostri corsi d'acqua da
un po di anni a questa parte a causa
dell'incuria dei territori a causa degli
sconvolgimenti climatici
la mattina del 3 ottobre nel 2020
riceverò un messaggio è un'immagine che
mi farà sapere che nella notte il
torrente cervo esondando ha distrutto
portandosi via la palazzina che contiene
alla mia opera sonora e tutti i suoi
suoni che si è ripreso indietro in
qualche modo chiudendo il cerchio
artistico ea quel punto saprò di aver
fatto la scelta giusta
dopo aver lavorato per michelangelo
pistoletto arrivano tantissime proposte
di per mettere in musica luoghi elementi
della natura
fra le tante mi entusiasma
particolarmente la proposta della onlus
world race che mi chiede di realizzare
una sorta di sinfonia con i suoni
dell'oceano venendo in contatto con
maria sole bianco
vengo in contatto con un altro mondo
pieno di meraviglia per esempio dalle
sue parole
imparo che i capodogli sono in grado
attraverso i loro suoni di comunicare da
una parte all'altra dell'oceano e sono
anche capaci di accarezzarsi mettendo
onde sonore come gesti d'affetto ma la
cosa più sconvolgente è incredibile è
che esistono al mondo varietà e specie
di pesci in grado di radunarsi una certa
ora della sera e cantare in coro con la
stessa vena crepuscolare degli uccelli e
mettendo dei suoni di possibili a questo
anzi e mettendo proprio questo suono
una volta campionato e armonizzato mi
permetterà di esprimere una tessitura
armonica di questo tipo
poi lavorerò con più comunemente noti
canti delle balene cercando di costruire
un immaginario piano balena ho avuto
chiamarlo intonando limb asso e se
queste rizzato
[Musica]
otterrà una soluzione di questo tipo fra
le mille cose incredibili relative
l'oceano che io non conoscevo
imparo anche che l'oceano e responsabile
della metà dei respiri che noi facciamo
ci regala 50 per cento dell'ossigeno che
noi respiriamo e che a causa
dell'acidificazione delle acque e
l'innalzamento della temperatura delle
stesse questa funzionalità può venire
compromessa realizzerò quindi questa
sinfonia viene un po da ridere chiamarla
così un brano senza strumenti in quattro
movimenti l'ultimo dei quali
drammaticamente sarà sostenuto
ritmicamente dal suono dal rumore della
rottura dei ghiacciai a causa dello
scioglimento a causa delle temperature
questa cosa e perché l'oceano ci ricorda
con l'innalzamento delle sue acque
i danni che le stiamo facendo la nostra
stessa casa
[Musica]
un altro dei personaggi credibili
incontrati nel questo percorso e stefano
mancuso il celebre studioso delle piante
mi ha regalato la sua registrazione del
rumore che emettono le radici per
orientarsi nel terreno e la cosa più
incredibile è che questo rumore
preesistente rispetto a qualsiasi
presenza umana sulla terra risulta
essere una sorta di rumore tecnologico
quasi un disturbo digitale non lo faccio
sentire non semplice riuscire a estrarre
a costruire degli strumenti immaginari
da questo suono riesco attraverso un
campionatore granulare a mandarlo in
risonanza ea creare delle note come
queste
che intonate anche in basso
[Musica]
vi permetteranno di immaginare di poter
realizzare un brano che ho voluto che
raffigurasse in qualche modo
rappresentasse la foresta vista
dall'esterno per come la conosciamo
attraverso le foglie e rami la
fisionomia degli alberi ma anche
indagata sottoterra dove la foresta
svolge la sua più intensa attività
cognitiva e dove addirittura le piante
riescano a connettersi a comunicare le
une con le altre
otterrò un brano mi faccio sentire pochi
secondi di questo tipo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
tutto quello che ascoltate e esattamente
la radice di una di una pianta messa in
musica non ci sono altri strumenti
musicali
mi ritrovo a questo a quel punto a
lavorare con i soli della natura nella
prima fase del primo look da uno che
tutti quanti immagino ricordiamo
benissimo da fuori dalla mia finestra
c'è una città desertificata bloccata
quella città che mi ha sempre dato
l'ispirazione per la mia musica per i
miei ritmi per i miei brani per i miei
testi in quel momento non stava non mi
sta dando nulla nostrano stai mettendo
nessun segnale però durante le lunghe
settimane come potete immaginare passati
a contatto con i suoni della natura ogni
volta che metto le cuffie sono
improvvisamente a contatto con un
dinamismo lontano che mi parla anche del
fatto che probabilmente la natura si
stia si sta riprendendo degli spazi
allora è lì che provo a immaginare con
un po di presunzione di poter fare un
album senza strumenti musicali in
qualche modo ispirato al mondo che che
ci aspetterà fuori da quella porta
immaginando anche nella prima fase così
emotivamente intensa di quel look da un
immaginando di rivolgermi ad un mondo
che potrebbe essere anche migliore alla
ricerca di altri elementi della natura
quel punto da raccontare penso alle api
al loro visto di rischio di estinzione
la loro importanza per quanto riguarda
la catena alimentare contatto un
apicultore e vi presento davanti alle
sue anni con dei microfoni cercando di
capire anche lì che storia vorrei
raccontare dopo poche parole
dell'apicoltore capisco che l'elemento
centrale al mio brano sarà la regina
ovvero la figura attorno al quale ruota
tutta la vita dell'alveare ma che
qualche modo mi sembra intrappolata
malinconicamente nel suo ruolo regnante
un po come la marie antoniette del film
di sofia coppola per chi per chi l'ha
visto deciderò che la reggina sarà
l'elemento centrale di cerano quindi di
fare un brano di musica barocca
anche perché il verso dell'ape regina e
un verso che sembra quasi uscire da un
lancio
che io trasformerò in una specie di oboe
immaginario dopo di che fra le altre
cose incredibili ascolto il fatto che le
api prendono alcune tra le decisioni più
importanti per la vita della loro
comunità danzando quando la vecchia
regina si stacca dall'alveare e parte
dell'alveare la segue l'esploratrice
cercheranno un posto dove andare a
vivere e per scegliere il posto dove
andare a vivere
danzeranno le coordinate di un luogo e
più ap esplorati ship insieme danzeranno
queste coordinate e più orienteranno la
scelta di questa democrazia dance
proviamo a immaginare nella società
degli uomini se potessimo sostituire la
guerra o anche solo la brutalità del
dibattito politico per come lo
conosciamo con un armoniosa danza
[Musica]
oggi che pensiamo all'ambiente con una
sensazione di ansia e di minaccia perché
conosciamo perfettamente le scadenze
sentir parlare di api che danzano di
pesci che cantano di radici che suonano
beh può regalarci qualcosa in più può
regalarci un senso di quasi gioiose di
empatia nei confronti proprio degli
ecosistemi che dovremmo tutelare e
proteggere con delle soluzioni il più
possibile creative
questo è il senso profondo di questo
lavoro di harmonia poi se non ci saremmo
riusciti se dovremmo in qualche modo mi
creare su marte o su qualche altro
pianeta
avremo una colonna sonora della nostra
terra che ci porteremo dietro per
ricordarci il nostro paradiso perduto
grazie
[Applauso]